Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo nos
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
un juicio contra la solidaridad en
Europa en 2015 lesbos en Grecia fue el
principal puerto de entrada de migrantes
al continente entre ellos llegaron Sara
y llus ramardini dos nadadoras
profesionales que huyeron de Siria su
historia inspiró una película pero ahora
una de ellas es procesada por ayudar a
migrantes y refugiados a Sara se le
prohibió entrar a Grecia para ser
juzgada en un proceso que lleva al
estrado a un total de 24 trabajadores
humanitarios por sus labores de rescate
fotografía del pasado septiembre en el
Festival Internacional de Cine de
Toronto Sara mardini asiste al estreno
de las nadadoras un largometraje
inspirado en la historia de ella y su
hermana josra que huyeron de la guerra
en Siria la película relata La Peligrosa
travesía de estas campeonas de natación
por el Mar Egeo hasta su llegada a
Grecia durante 2015 el año de la crisis
de refugiados en Europa
[Música]
un viaje que llevaría a yusra a los
Juegos Olímpicos de 2016 y 2020 donde
compitió como parte del equipo de
refugiados pero la película no cuenta lo
que le ocurrió después a Sara volvió a
Grecia y allí durante dos años ayudó a
refugiados hasta que fue detenida en
2018 en el aeropuerto de lesbos estuvo
encarcelada más de tres meses antes de
quedar en Libertad bajo fianza Y ser
deportada con la prohibición de volver
incluso para comparecer ante un tribunal
durante más de cuatro años ella y otros
23 trabajadores humanitarios han estado
a la espera de un juicio acusados de
pertenecer a una organización criminal
los juzgan por tráfico de personas
blanqueo de dinero fraude y espionaje
uno señalamientos que los llevarían a
pagar hasta 25 años de prisión en un
juicio que los 24 acusados y sus
abogados denuncian como políticamente
motivado
el caso de Sara y de los más de 20
activistas procesados en Grecia no es el
único en Europa que penaliza la acción
humanitaria ongs como amnistía
internacional denuncia castigos a
cientos de personas en Italia Grecia
Francia y Suiza en estos dos últimos
países siete guías de montaña fueron
señalados de ser traficantes tras
asistir a migrantes bloqueados en la
nieve más datos en el siguiente informe
prohibiciones intimidación y Castigo en
varios países europeos se amenaza a
quienes ayudan a migrantes y refugiados
el objetivo desincentivar la solidaridad
una criminalización que no solo está
dirigida a activistas de diferentes ong
también a personas anónimas que le
brindan a los recién llegados desde un
plato de comida hasta información muchas
de las investigaciones y los procesos
penales abiertos se basan en delitos
como la ayuda a la entrada a la
circulación y a la estancia irregular en
un país miembro de la Unión Europea
según denuncia amnistía internacional
unas prácticas condenatorias que
Naciones Unidas pide reevaluar salvar
vidas y brindar asistencia humanitaria
nunca deben criminalizarse ni
enjuiciarse tales acciones son
simplemente un imperativo humanitario y
de Derechos Humanos
mientras se penaliza la solidaridad El
Éxodo continúa en la ruta más mortífera
para los migrantes la del Mediterráneo
las labores de rescate no paran a
principios de enero más de 70 personas
incluidos 16 menores no acompañados se
les permitió desembarcar en Italia pero
el país sigue restringiendo el trabajo
de las organizaciones de ayuda estamos
obviamente estamos aliviados de haber
logrado rescatar a todos a tiempo en
cambio ayer en este mar alguien más tuvo
menos suerte hubo un naufragio frente a
la costa de lampedusa y tres personas
perdieron la vida entre ellas una niña
muy pequeña de solo unos meses Esto es
lo que provocan las políticas
migratorias de Europa y los países
costeros las ong deben suplir de alguna
manera la falta de coordinación en la
búsqueda y rescate de personas en
peligro en este tramo del mar y la falta
de vías seguras de acceso para escapar
de Libia
en Italia un decreto del ejecutivo que
dice regula las operaciones de rescate
ordena a los barcos de ayuda solicitar
un puerto luego del encuentro de un bote
a la deriva y les exige dirigirse hacia
él inmediatamente sin oportunidad de
buscar a más personas en el mar quienes
lo hagan se arriesgan a las multas y al
eventual confiscación de sus barcos
organizaciones en Europa denuncian que
el cierre de fronteras y las políticas
de disuasión priman sobre el respeto a
los Derechos Humanos por lo que pidan a
los Estados abordar urgentemente esta
cuestión para asegurar su asistencia con
plenas garantías y el dato de migración
de la semana casi 250.000 migrantes
cruzaron La Peligrosa selva del Darién
entre Colombia y Panamá durante 2022 una
cifra que casi duplica la reportada en
2021 por la organización internacional
para las migraciones el reporte señala
que unas 36 personas murieron durante el
viaje pero la oim advierte que el número
sería mucho mayor
hasta que migrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]